it does seem like Nickelodeon actors are
a lot better off afterwards than the
Disney Channel actor it's because we're
less famous do you think so yeah I do I
mean not all of us Nickelodeon
apparently there's a lot coming out with
a lot of Nickelodeon actors who have
up experiences man it breaks my
heart to here but Disney has a better
machine I had an overall good experience
on Nickelodeon but so did a bunch of the
Disney kids it really depends on who's
running your show Ned's was made by a
guy named Scott fellows who is an
incredible human he's a great family man
hilarious guy his wife produces with him
his kids are on set it was a blast